قد يكون هناك أخيرًا بصيص أمل
للأشخاص الذين يعانون من مرض الزهايمر
وافقت إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) اليوم على
علاج جديد مثير للجدل للأشخاص في
المراحل الأولى من المرض المدمر
، وهو أول دواء لمرض الزهايمر
تمت الموافقة عليه منذ 20 عامًا
ولكن تثار أسئلة جدية
حول العقار.  فعالية
CNN تنضم إليزابيث كوهين كبير المراسلين الطبيين الآن ، فلماذا
توجد أسئلة حول ما إذا كان
هذا الدواء يعمل بالفعل ومع ذلك
فقد تمت الموافقة عليه الآن من قبل إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) ،
لذا عندما تسمع عن عقار جديد
لمرض ألزهايمر ،
فأنت تعلم أن هناك أملًا من هذا القبيل
يعرفه الجميع.  شخص مصاب بمرض الزهايمر ،
إنه مرض مدمر رهيب
، ولذا فإن الأمل هو أن
حبيبي يمكنه تناول هذا الدواء
وسأعيده مرة أخرى ،
هذا ليس ما هو هذا الدواء ،
فلنوضح أنه للاستخدام
في المراحل المبكرة جدًا من مرض الزهايمر
حتى الباحثون أنفسهم
قالوا إنه إذا كان لدي مريض متقدم في العمر ،
فلن أعطي هذا الدواء لهم ، لذلك
دعونا نرغب  حسنًا ، كيف كان أداء هذا الدواء
حتى في مرضى المرحلة المبكرة نظرًا
لوجود خلافات هناك أيضًا ،
كانت هناك دراسة تم إجراؤها
إذا لم تنجح في عدم
فعاليتها
، ثم كانت هناك دراسة أخرى
أظهرت أنها أدت إلى 22  في المائة أو
كان مرتبطًا
بتخفيض بنسبة 22 في المائة في
التطور
المعرفي ، وبعبارة أخرى ، فقد حسن الأشياء بمقدار
ميكرونًا ، وهذا أمر جيد ولكن 22
قد يلاحظ المريض أن هذا
يترجم حقًا
إلى أي نوع من التغييرات في
حياة ذلك المريض.
قامت إدارة الأغذية والعقاقير (FDA) بعمل شيئين غير مألوفين للغاية
هنا ،
أحدهما قالته اللجنة الاستشارية قبل أشهر ،
لا نعتقد أنه يجب عليك
الموافقة على هذا الدواء ، فنحن لا نرى أنه
فعال ،
لقد خالفوا نصيحة
مستشاريهم ، وهو أمر نادر
الحدوث ، والشيء الثاني هو  قالت الوكالة أنك
تعرف ما الذي سنوافق عليه
لأنه عندما تنظر إلى الدراسات يمكنك أن
ترى أنها تقلل
من كمية لويحات الأميلويد ، تلك
هي اللويحات والتشابكات في
الدماغ المرتبط بمرض الزهايمر
قالوا إنه يمكنك رؤية
هذا لذا من المعقول الاعتقاد بأنه
سيساعد هؤلاء
المرضى ولذا وافقوا عليه في هذا النوع من
القفز هناك الآن الكثير من الانتقادات التي
يقول الناس أن السوبر قد يكون عقارًا باهظ الثمن
هذا قد لا يفعل كثيرا
آنا